oh my God wasn't he incredible he was
amazing so good and so cute I know yeah
it is great to meet you I literally love
everything you do you're one of those
actors for me that I will literally
watch if I see your face I'll just watch
it well I thank you for that you pick
great projects and you're also
incredible I try I try thank you
um you you and I have never met but I
feel that I prior to today but I feel
that I've met you through that song of
yours because of you oh that song is so
powerful so honest so beautiful your
performance of it so moving to me if I
do any work at all any role that I play
has that kind of effect on someone that
it had on that that song had on me I'll
be doing okay it's
like Perfect song perfect you are very
nice oh you're good and always welcome
here feel really good oh my gosh wait so
you were raised in DC so like when did
you get into theater oh I got into
theater uh when I was younger I didn't
start acting until I was a junior in
college but uh I I would go to the
theater when I was a kid um my my first
experience was a friend of my mothers a
woman uh that I knew as Aunt row who was
a public school teacher as well and she
took me to see uh uh Oliver uh dinner
theater you know iiver iiv he says his
name is Olive I mean that was like the
introduction I was like four years old
captivated yeah and uh and then my mom
would take me to the theater she was a
lawyer she wanted me to go to law school
she wanted me to or even medical school
I think but she planted the seed for
acting in me early she would take me to
every New York show that would tour
through Washington so we would go to the
Fords theater and the National Theater
and we would see everything from The
Whiz to Annie to a oneman show show uh
that James Whitmore did called give him
hell Harry about Harry Truman and we saw
everything and uh I kind of fell in love
with it I was enthralled by those nights
I remember as a kid you know seven eight
years old when the curtain went down at
the end of the show I was convinced that
the world of the play went on afterwards
it was out there and I want and I wanted
I wanted to be a part of it it was uh
the magic it was it was just it was
magical for me certainly so you said Not
until Junior in college so like wait
what took you so long cuz you're so
great what you know if I'm honest I'm
like what were you doing I'm like what
if I'm if I'm honest I was kind of
afraid of it I would I would have these
weird dreams even then even before I
started acting that I was on stage and
the words just wouldn't come you choke I
I just freeze up and in fact I did uh
Christmas Pageant I played when I was in
like kindergarten or something like that
I played one of the three wise men I
ended up bringing Franken
stench is that what you said I said
Franken
stench I said you know maybe I'll lay
this down for a while maybe it's not my
thing oh my God that's amazing it's
almost worse though when you have like
one or two lines rather than many so
much it's so much pressure so much
Weighing on that one line on that one
stench I feel
like you probably made everyone's night
it was like the comic relief well there
is this other story that I heard about
when you were doing is it bosia when you
when you was it David Bowie yeah what in
the world this story is incredible to me
yeah like there's so much to this story
so you met him with basat right I did
that was uh that was a a photo shoot
that we did when we were promoting the
film but the first time that I met him
and he meant the world to me and I there
were periods in my life where his music
was a soundtrack I mean he was just he
is a soundtrack you know I mean come on
so um I had the chance uh to paint for
about 6 months before uh filming began
Julian schneble who directed the film
allowed me access to his studio and I
would be in there painting sometimes
there would be 20 bosot you know real uh
pieces of his work lined up and I would
take a bit from one and a bit from
another and just try to try to make
myself comfortable with his aesthetic
and his style and also with the act of
painting yeah had you ever painted
before then a little bit a little bit
not not not as much as I had then yeah
did then but I uh so I'm down on my you
know on this canvas one day and the door
opens and walks David Bowie sure cuz
he's playing he's going to play uh Andy
Warhol in the movie and he walks in and
I'm down there and he kneels down next
to me and he says uh he says do you mind
if I watch and I said well uh I think
I'm going to have to get used to it yeah
so uh but like absolutely not says my
soul terrifi and we but we had to laugh
at that you know and and from then on I
mean he was just so generous and so
smart and funny and I mean he couldn't
have been cooler to me I remember one
day we were in the hair and makeup
trailer Gary Oldman was in the uh the
the film as well we're sitting there and
David walks in he goes right you say you
you want to hear some music and we're
like huh like his music like his his
music like yeah David Bowie we'll
tolerate your music here yeah sure put
in little disc there and and so he puts
in his new album that has not come out
yet and it's an album called outside
some of the music is featured in the
film because it's kind of reminiscent of
the story in some ways and he uh his his
guitarist was named Reeves gabell and he
plays this really abstracted beautiful
stuff and we're listening to it we're
like whoa and Davidson there air
guitaring to his own
music and it was like it was like you
know know the cool guy at school who
found some who found some obscure record
somewhere and brought it in except the
cool guy was David Boe that was like
amazing it was like I love that
story yeah not many people get those
moment incredible it was so wonderful
and then um he went on tour with 9in
nails uh featuring that album and this
was before our film came out I think of
maybe six or seven months after we'd
finished filming and not a lot of people
knew knew that album or they certainly
didn't know it as as I did I'd you know
been listening to it since I first heard
it he gave me a a copy so I'm at this uh
I'm at this concert out at the meal
lands and I'm like hey this is Dave this
is me and David's thing you know it was
like he was feel like the only one that
knows the music and you're sitting there
like you're welcome yeah he was he was
so wonderful I I me it was just such a
gift to me early in my career my first
lead in a film to have David Bo Dennis
Hopper Chris Watkin once again you're in
a film with no one I mean you
[Applause]
know keep keep an keep an eye out for
those guys they're going to be doing
some you're going to hear about them yes
well wait speaking of great films I'm
I'm certain I'm not like look I'm gonna
do this because I'm a little sub I'm
certain you're gonna be nominated for an
Oscar for this so it's American fiction
so explain the movie it's so the idea of
it is so good how you play it out how
his imagination plays out it's so
incredible to explain it to people oh
thank you it's a story about a man uh
his name is Thelonius Monk Ellison he
writes uh stuff he's a smart guy he
writes smart stuff but nobody wants to
read his stuff so out of frustration he
decides to write what he thinks is uh
you know an urban novel for the masses
and he writes it under an assumed name
uh stag R Le uh as a as a prank to like
you know point out the hypocrisy of the
publishing world he sends this thing off
uh and it blows up it becomes his
biggest selling novel and uh so he's
left leading this kind of weird dual
life where he's got to pretend that he's
this fugitive who wrote the novel
meanwhile his family is going through
crisis really crisis after crisis and
he's left trying to be a caretaker of
the entire family but specifically of
his mother so there's this wonderful
contrast between the absurdity of the
perception of him and really the kind of
uh ordinariness the extraordinary in
some ways ordinariness because we rarely
see stories like this or a family family
like this of his actual life yeah I
could relate a lot and intimately to
this need for this man to take care of
his mother my mom passed away about a
year before I got this script and I
understood the the pressures that that
brings all of a sudden and I understand
the sacrifices that that asked of a
person uh professionally and and
personally and so I was really I really
felt very close to this character's uh
Journey but going back to your song but
because of you you know the the
isolation that you express in that I
mean it's really very similar in some
ways to this character story you know
unfortunately a lot of people relate to
that you know a feeling you can't like
you know let anyone in and his brother
comes to him and tries to open him up a
little bit it's a really beautiful
moment it's interesting cuz you say that
cuz actually how I write is how your
character kind of does in the like I
always have a movie playing like I
always have like some imagery is always
present like anytime I'm writing that's
interesting and so that's the same kind
of thing was happening like when I was
writing because of you so yeah it's just
W CU I draw so much inspiration from
musicians in in my work that's what's so
funny people always ask me who are my
favorite people that inspire me a lot of
them are actors and I'm not an actor but
I I have a lot of singers that I like
love obviously that I grew up and adore
and imitate quite frequently but like I
but there people don't get how it
doesn't matter it's art so yeah art is
always inspiring art even if it's not
the same thing you if could see a
painting and it you know Sparks a song
or something yeah yeah Marlon Brando
once said about actors an actor is a guy
who if you ain't talking about him he
ain't listening so so so so you know so
here I am talking
about we we talked about you know DC
childhood but what was like your first
job there oh wow my first job in
DC was through a program called The
Summer Youth Employment
Program exactly this is a popular
program well begun by Marian Barry who
you know was obviously was controversial
in some respects but this program
provided the first jobs for thousands of
kids in DC I was one of them I had a job
working in a swimming pool in
anacosta in a in a in a pretty tight
neighborhood uh uh I was working in the
locker room basically taking kids
clothes and you know stuffing them while
they went and had fun in the pool I was
about 14 or 15 years old uh and that job
ended before it was supposed to have uh
it did we we did the pool didn't make it
through the entire summer I think uh oh
my God early August we got shut down
there was a riot that occurred uh
somebody got kicked out of the
pool she didn't appreciate that she came
back with her folks and uh yeah it was
on they brought you know bricks head
clippers for a k thankfully that was my
day off oh my God you lucky man was not
there but it was an incredible it was an
incredible program uh that uh that
program uh and in fact later uh I ended
up working in the office of the Summer
Youth Employment Program the following
year giving kids jobs connecting them
with opportunities was super gratifying
like you know okay dude sit down take
your hat off all right you want to work
yeah it was so cool yeah great
[Music]
[Applause]
program thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going home oh